I am going to make a video a series of
videos about split time opposites
warplane combinations for the series you
will need to already know and really
brush up on the basic patterns diamond
for petal if you spin also its cousin
box for petal aunty spin to do to a
spins on the horizontals and to in spins
on the verticals those are all take
three circles and if that's confusing
try my step-by-step beyond the basics
poi spinning course it goes through all
of this stuff builds it up step by step
and scribe with links you will also need
to know the for circle patterns so that
is our upward pointing five petal
interestin and our downward pointing
five petal and piston and they're
cousins which is in spins the in spins
straight the top and then on angles at
the bottom and of course the inverse of
that which is in spin at the bottom and
angles the top like a why
so we're gonna want to have to put all
this together in different formations
all in split time opposites
you also need really clean play Fuu so
people tend to do this this art gets
ahead and you want to be able to make
really clean circles where they're
always one above the other and some
space inside your arms and we're gonna
put together different ways and sui fun
and it's summertime and it's a great
time to play play these by the way are
pod play 2.0 it's really awesome and
they're really bright which is why they
show up so well and it can be fun making
many videos with them and we're gonna
side you get a pair those use my code
that's it and suppress from those
patterns and then we'll see where we can
go with